back in the spotlight
what happened in downing street
and behind this door during coveted
lockdowns after the police today
concluded staff did break the rules
should the prime minister resign if he's
fine sir
a question on everyone's lips but weeks
ago then the world changed i think there
are many many more important issues you
know people are literally dying in
ukraine there's a cost of living
challenge the government needs to be
focused on that they're focused for now
elsewhere and while the pm was not fine
today the police clear that more fines
could be on the way this investigation
far from over
and those lost in this pandemic never
forgotten either
a year to day since this wall in
westminster was created to remember
those who died a moment of reflection
but anger too at the prime minister and
those who partied at such a sensitive
time that should never have happened and
we feel betrayed
as a group brief families we feel very
let down by the government that they
behaved in this way when the rest of us
were making so many
sacrifices but some of his own mps even
those who called for his resignation say
now not the time the issue of partygate
has for better or worse been swamped by
international events in ukraine i think
it's going to be overtaken by domestic
issues around the cost of living
there may be um
a price to pay for partygate
there may be a day of reckoning but it's
certainly not now the opposition though
clear the damage already done no future
for this pm transparency is important
and trust and confidence in our prime
minister is important if he's broken his
own rules which is clear he has then he
should resign and if he gets a fixed
penalty notice or he tries to scapegoat
other people then i think that says more
about him as a person
we still don't know if the prime
minister will be fined for breaking his
own lock down rules but what we do now
know is that his assertion that all
guidelines were followed under his roof
is simply untrue lockdown laws were
broken in downing street what's clearer
too though is that even if the prime
minister is fined which in itself would
be unprecedented the immediate threat to
his leadership has receded with
conservative mps reluctant to try to
oust a sit-in prime minister during a
war
here tonight a dinner and drinks for
conservative mps a pm trying to get his
back benchers back on side morale's
pretty good actually
but the ultimate deciders of his fate
will be the public and will they forgive
and forget beth rigby sky news
westminster